this is everyday I'm day and this is a
clip from The Upright Citizens Brigade
sketch show
hey where's building me like to eat he
likes to eat at the pump room great
here's what you do go to the bank today
get yourself fifty dollars in pennies
stick them all up your ass one at a time
of course you go to the pump room buy
yourself a nice dinner paying entirely
in pennies now they'll be using your
pennies for next week at least
Bellamy goes in there to eat he gets
your ass pennies for change by the time
you meet with him you know he said
something in his hand that you've had in
your ass so so then you get the upper
hand no I don't yeah you do it's just
like imagining someone in their
underwear no it's not
it's horrible yeah well it works for me
you know what I used to look up to you I
used to think you really had it together
oh I do have it together little brother
you don't pull down eight figures a year
without having it together you don't
have it together Nick you stick pennies
up your ass for confidence that's not
having it together
so why are we watching a clip from The
Upright Citizens Brigade you might be
wondering I'll tell you it's because
it's the 20th anniversary of the show
it's a big week for you see because
they're not only a sketch show they've
also got this improv and sketch comedy
theater and this week in New York City
is the Del Close marathon an improv
comedy festival where you can go watch
three straight days of improv that
sounds pretty cool right guys I love UCB
it's where I got my comedy start which
is what I want to talk about today with
it also a way that that's shared from
[Laughter]
well I like so what I want to talk about
is where did all of you get your comedy
star so that's our discussion topic for
today if you had any advice to give to
your younger self someone who's starting
out in comedy what would you tell him
man I got my start at UCB as well I
would say I regret not sending people
emails where like they just got their
first comedy job and I don't I'm not
really friends with them
and I'm just gonna ask them hey you got
a comedy job can I also work there
that's the best way to get a commie job
yep can you do me a big favor right now
that you have this a little bit of yep
this means you're about to get a ton of
email I know people are not gonna read
the sarcasm
I would so I feel like when I started
people would always be like oh what's
your like voice you know like what's
your style and I think that's not
helpful to like guess what kind of thing
you're doing just do the thing I found
out what I like to do in my voice once I
started doing stuff I think we have a
tendency to spend way too much time
thinking about like you know what it is
we want to say just like make stuff and
then start down just do stuff and then
you'll know exactly what you're supposed
to say and do what you say I would say
if I had to talk to my younger self they
relax with the carbs Chris don't be a
woman don't do I did bring her shows
when I started which is you like pay you
have to bring five people it's like $80
a ticket and then it's 20 horrible
comedians myself included and my friends
now never come to a show because they
all my friends more piece of real advice
okay which is feels counterintuitive but
this is based off of Ryan said like hang
out with people like when I was first
starting I was like I can only do shows
like and I was just so vigilant about
not hanging out with other friends and
just focusing on doing shows and then as
soon as I stopped and started like
spending time with people I realized
that's where the material is I agree
with a lot of people go live regular
life I do so much regular leister like
my friend because we're you going you go
to another show no more to a concert and
just now who's go what you don't care I
have a ticket if somebody shows up I'll
give it to them I don't really get to do
as much regular human stuff as be a
human human being
okay be a human hang out with funny
people make stuff and it'll all work out
we promise Mendes John Cena we know he's
a wrestler a movie star and a
humanitarian but who really is John Cena
today I ask the hard questions question
how big is John Cena more specifically
is he bigger than a general sherman
sequoia answer inconclusive both john
cena and the general sherman sequoia
have been growing at a rapid rate since
1977 question is john cena related to a
honey badger answer technically no but
theoretically yes honey badgers are
notorious for their strength ferocity
and toughness they have been known to
savagely and fiercely attack almost any
kind of animal when Escape is impossible
one might say John Cena is the honey
badger of the WWE or that the honey
badger is the John Cena of the weasel
family question how many degrees
separate Jackie Chan and John Cena
answer one just the sliver of air in
between that undeniable chemistry you
know it doesn't separate them an
understanding of Mandarin yeah John Cena
can straight-up speak Mandarin like
Allah then sure don't shoot your hole or
the John where's your mom oh ho
what does John Cena hate bandages sharks
that steal his jewelry and Tony Shalhoub
what does John Cena like Wonka bars uh
and framed photos of food if John Cena
could go back in time what would he
change his vasectomy
in fact he's getting it reversed so he
and Nicole Bella can have a baby mm-hmm
looks like John Cena scrotum tubes are
getting and attitude adjustment
in conclusion who is John Cena a
multimillion-dollar start yeah that's
what people who don't really know him
say but to the people who really know
him you and me
who's John Cena's why he's a honey
badger like Tony Shalhoub hating
mandarin-speaking Sukhoi of a man who
will soon be able to get you pregnant
this has been who is John Cena this is
Wonder Years this is a game where I'm
gonna read some real facts about the
past of our contestants Hannah Chris and
then our studio audience these guys are
gonna have to guess which one of them it
applies to let's get started does that
make us the contestants well you know
first back had their first drink in
sixth grade who do you think it was at
their first drink in sixth grade
oh we were split correct answer Hannah
didn't kind of actually waited till I
was 21 to take my fridge but a good boy
kiss in eighth grade who do we think had
their first kiss in eighth grade who or
split once again correct answer was your
first kiss obviously with my first drink
in the sixth grade
okay this person published a newspaper
about ass cracks in elementary school
and got in trouble we're all going with
Chris correct answer okay so this person
sold bootleg mixtape CDs out of their
locker this person ran versity track
freshman year but then junior varsity
track sophomore Oh again correct answer
[Music]
I was going through a lot this person
was an undercover limp Biskit and Smash
Mouth fan you boy cheated on and then
threw ice cream on the person's head in
retaliation six fake IDs growing up six
fake IDs six that's a lot who split
who's it gonna be now this person was
booed off stage the first three times
they did stand up by name we got two for
Chris Jordan oh and once again Oh Chris
what are you doing up there that was
literally a quote that's
okay last one this person refused to
poop in a public bathroom or this person
refuses to poop in public bathrooms oh
wow look over here at the very end let
me check the point out right here that
means that Ryan wins right at the end
with these two it's like I'm the
reigning studio audience member this
morning I saw that Ryan lifts out his
yogurt by his lap again and I got a lot
of publicly for doing that I took a
photo of it yeah I didn't have any post
it in the comment I don't like yogurt
then what was the thing I saw someone
else's yogurt who's Jordan nothing his
laptop
why did he do that with the yogurt man
it's gross and it's a health hazard man
I really thought I was gonna get you
good when I brought this up again Oh
someone else near my computer and here
you are trying to lambast me back on me
getting lambasted dealt with every day
[Music]
you